it is the quiet moments that are most
unnerving as we move through a war zone
that feels like a relic from another
century
their weapons may be modern but the
defensive network that zigzags this
wasteland
looks no different from the trenches
that cut through the western front all
those years ago
thick mud clags boots
and with the prospects of an invasion
growing these soldiers are fighting not
just for ukraine's future but against
the ghosts of the past haunting this
eastern front line
it's been pretty intermittent we've
heard the sound
of a couple of grenades land nearby and
what we're being told is because the
weather's clear
they expect it to carry on like this for
the rest of the day we're having to keep
very low because of the threat of
snipers
but the big fear for the soldiers here
is that this could be the sign that
things are about to escalate
broken factories have become rat runs a
way of staying safe moving between
positions
the incoming artillery is more intense
than it has been for ages
it's an ominous sign in the face of
faltering diplomacy so i don't know what
is the in the head of the putin and we
are ready for this
because it's also our job we must be
preparing for the worst of the situation
so you think invasion could come no it's
it's possible
it's extreme situation and of course we
to be worried about this it's normal in
this situation
the soldiers can only look out with
periscopes their enemy is just a few
hundred meters away
and as the kremlin continues to
renegotiate europe's security through
the barrel of a gun
they know here that fighting with the
russian-backed separatists could break
out at any moment
we've just moved back from the front
lines
we're hearing the sound of quite
sustained fire now and
the soldiers who've been escorting us
have been given order and order by their
commander that all non-military
personnel need to now move back
away from these positions
after eight years of war what comes next
in this grim conflict is still a
guessing game
but the soldiers here as they face
another freezing day on the front
say they're ready to defend their
country and their freedom
alex rossi's sky news on the front line
near donetsk